reste un petit peu de temps pour parler
du travail du dimanche deux salariés de
l'enseigné cora employés à saint malo
ont été licenciés je vous propose
d'écouter l'une de ces deux personnes
c'est christelle laurent elle explique
pourquoi elle a été licenciée moins
posée mais dimanche parce que moi j'ai
refusé on me l'a imposé à partir du fin
mi janvier plus d'une mi janvier 2009
mon chef m'a obligé je suis revenu de
vacances se dit d'avril mises à pied
direct suivi d'une procédure de
licenciement alors on avait pourtant cru
comprendre que le travail du dimanche
c'était était facultatif regardez ce
point de vue de force ouvrière qui
publiait un communiqué pour dire que
cette décision ces licenciements
confirme les incohérences du dj slater
et les dérives ouvertes par la loi
macron 2015
laquelle en multipliant les dérogations
vidé de son sens le principe du repos
dominical alors en fait il ya deux il ya
deux idées différentes il ya le premier
sujet c'est est ce que le travail du
dimanche est ou non obligatoire est ce
qu'il ne doit être que les volets les
salariés pardon doivent être forcément
volontaire et puis le deuxième sujet
c'est quelle sont les magasins qui
peuvent ou ne peuvent pas ouvrir le
dimanche et c'est à ces dérogations que
le communiqué de force ouvrière faisait
allusion voici l'avis de nos internautes
le licenciement de ses deux salariés de
cora vous choque-t-il et vous répondez
oui à 80 importance quand on peut donc
penser que vous les considérez comme
injuste emmanuelle barbara vous pouvez
nous rappeler l'état du droit sur ce sur
ce sujet c'est horriblement complexe et
très aimable gentil
alors dans l'ordre d'apparition je peux
dire le travail le dimanche d'abord
c'est un mot qui braquent encore fas qui
braquent on voit bien qui est qui touche
quand même aux anneaux aux tabous
historique si je puis dire mais enfin on
est passé au travers de ces sujets petit
à petit le drôle le principe c'est que
le repos du travailleur du salarié c'est
le dimanche c'est écrit en toutes
lettres dans le code du travail c'est
toujours le cas
c'est le jour traditionnel du repos
hebdomadaire c'est le dimanche sauf
dérogation alors les dérogations il y en
a effectivement de toutes sortes et y en
a de plusieurs j'allais dire de toutes
sortes qui sont j'allais dire venu dans
l'histoire du droit récente à des
moments différents
il ya la fameuse loi macron de 2015 et
puis il ya l'état du droit avant 2015
sur l'état du droit avant 2015
il y à une dérogation qui existe depuis
très longtemps c'est celle précisément
dans laquelle s'inscrit me semble-t-il
cette affaire de commerce alimente de
distribution que le commerce alimentaire
cette dérogation c'est un article du
code du travail 33 32 12 pour être
précise c'est pour faire chic cet
article pose et c'est avant la loi
macron donc ça n'a rien à voir avec le
libéralisme échevelé pose que pour
certains certaines activités dont celle
ci c'est à dire en gros de boulanger
le fleuriste et les supérettes ou les
supermarchés peuvent à titre dérogatoire
permanente ouvrir le dimanche jusqu'à 13
heures
donc l'état du droit était en grosse
addition de ce set ses affaires que le
dimanche est ouvert jusqu'à 13 heures
sans aucune espèce d'autorisation et
donc ça veut dire la convention
collective le reprenons que le jour le
dimanche est un jour de travail normal
jusqu'à 13 heures après il ya des
dérogations pour réclamer auprès du
préfet auprès du maire c'est les jours
du maire et puis il ya la loi macron sur
dans un cas dérogatoires sais pas si on
a le droit d'ouvrir le dimanche
est ce que un peu contrainte de salariés
ensuite de pression vous voyez on est
donc l'état du droit c'est que déjà on
est dans une dans un dans une thématique
ou dans un secteur d'activité où le
dimanche est un jour que j'allais dire
normal le demi dimanche pour le dimanche
entier c'est possible dans ce même
secteur mais là il faut demander une
autorisation pour l'après midi si je
puis dire du dimanche
et là il faut l'obtenir mais donc
supposons soit dans ce cas-là ça c'est
le règlementaire donc ça veut dire qu'
il n'y a pas lieu de s'émouvoir de cela
c'est possible et c'est donc licite en
soit c'est pas une affaire en 12 après
la question que l'on pose c'est
concrètement le dimanche est un jour
comme le lundi en gros est-ce que du
coup le dimanche je peux demander à mes
amis salariés de travailler à titre
obligatoire alors c'est là qu'il faut
rentrer dans les fesses et c'est à
partir de là que je ne je ne veux pas
répondre sur l' affaire en cours moi je
suis avocat je suis pas juge donc je
vais pas non plus jouer ce rôle là et en
plus le faire sans les faits c'est
épouvantable mais schématiquement dans
les dérogations dans les dégradés
dérogation récente estime d'ailleurs
celle de macron de 2015 c'est-à-dire qui
permet d'ouvrir en gros aux galeries
lafayette le dimanche
il faut un accord collectif et s'est
fondée exclusivement sur le volontariat
d'accord dans ces secteurs là donc dans
toutes les dérogations les plus les plus
récentes plus certaines autres donc
évidemment celui du dimanche après-midi
sera autorisation préfectorale c'est le
volontariat points je veux dire par là
que la loi ne précise pas a contrario
comme on dit fort sa maman que ce serait
obligatoire du coup pour le dimanche
matin pour faire très court dans notre
dans notre affaire on peut comprendre
que c'est obligatoire du commerçant
la dernier point de laitages de la fusée
c'est qu'il se trouve qu'il ya un
contrat de travail dans notre pays et
qu'il se trouve que dans le contrat de
travail fût-ce un contrat de travail
dans le secteur du commerce alimentaire
on précise les jours de travail c'est
comme ça pas en d'autres termes si je
dis ça n'a rien à voir avec le dimanche
mais si je dis qu'on travaille lundi
mardi et que soudain je déclare en tant
qu'employeur je voudrais que vous
travaillez le jeudi le vendredi je ne
peux pas l'imposer ça s'appelle une
modification du contrat de travail donc
la question est simple nous dans une
modification du contrat trajet lorsque
j'ai écrit dans le contrat
en d'autres termes c'est pas du
volontariat mais il ya un consentement
car ça s'appelle un contrat je reviens
en observations initiales comme a priori
ya pas consentement efficace voilà il ya
des lâchés pour garder le sujet yves
thréard très vite
je crois que tout a été dit l'allemand
willy après un peu philosophiquement
considérer oui mais on est alors il ya
deux choses
on est dans une société contractuelle de
marché capitaliste et tout repose sur le
contrat on est d'accord où on n'est pas
d'accord
si on n'est pas d'accord oh après il ya
une question philosophique je dirais
spirituelle à travers le travail
dominical
moi je fais partie de ceux qui suis pas
attaché je dirais à cette pause
dominicale ça divise ce qui tombe bien
quand on est journaliste au quotidien ça
divise énormément je sais la société
française est par exemple bien comme sur
l'europe dans tous les partis
enfin grosso modo au parti socialiste et
à droite et bien à droite c'est très
simple vous avez des libéraux qui vous
disent bas le dimanche est un jour comme
un autre et puis vous en avez d'autres
des conservateurs par exemple monsieur
bayrou qui est d'inspiration chrétienne
démocrate qui nous dit le dimanche c'est
sacré vous êtes plutôt libérale voilà et
vous alors moi je travaille alors
personnellement je travaille le dimanche
mais c'est vrai que je sais pas s'il
faut l'étendre cercle
le concept aussi peut-être d'un jour de
repos dans les têtes et je sais bien que
finalement c'est un petit peu
fantasmagorique parce qu'aujourd'hui les
gens qui ont beaucoup d'enfants c'est
comme s'ils travaillaient aussi parce
que ça plate et puisant aussi de
s'occuper de temps en temps de deux de
ses enfants donc un vrai jour de repos
est ce que ça existe aujourd'hui je ne
sais pas mais il est vrai que là dans
cette affaire on touche quand même à
quelque chose d'assez de 5,3 à dire que
s'il ya pas de résumé de rémunération
par don supplémentaire normalement ces
gens voilà son
elles sont dans leur droit et là on est
vraiment j'ai l'impression de revenir
trois en arrière ou comme vous l'avez
dit cette histoire avait divisé la
france met littéralement des débats
d'une passion folle beaucoup plus
importante que les autres débats
compenser inflammable quelques points de
vue d'internautes celui de nicole le
travail du dimanche ne devrait être que
sur volontariat est inscrit dans le
contrat de travail c'est un petit peu ce
que nous a expliqué manuel de barbara
bessat donc ses ambitions pas qu'ils
soient déjà le cas babineau rien de
choquant le dimanche n'est plus sacrée
en france c'est un jour comme les autres
alors que bergerie considèrent au
contraire qu'un jour de repos
hebdomadaire pour échapper un peu à la
sacro sainte consommation
ce n'est pas mal ça permette de
renforcer la vie sociale guillaume bigot
il avait un point de vue là dessus vous
travailler le dimanche à l'ipag on
travaille le dimanche
enfin oui oui il ya on vit dans une
société dans laquelle les limites
n'existent plus et je pense que la
pression du marché c'est un truisme de
le dire
la pression du marché s'est pas
seulement là la vectorisation de chaque
volonté individuelle à travers le
contrat dans une optique un peu 19e east
on est dans un monde dans lequel il ya
une sorte de maelström c'est le sait la
puissance du marché cette puissance de
marche elle s'appuie sur nous bien sûr
mais s'appuient davantage à mon avis sur
un bon plaisir individuel que sur une
idée du contrat raisonnée et c'est donc
dans cet univers moi j'étais tout à fait
favorable au libéralisme 13 pro
américain jusqu'à la chute du mur de
berlin à partir de la chute du mur de
berlin
je me suis complètement converti à une
vision non pas collectivise de la
société mais l'idée reste
on va les reconnaître il est contraint
pourquoi mais non c'est là contre
intuitif c'est que je pense que ça a
beaucoup de valeur les limites
aujourd'hui ont beaucoup de valeur
c'est fondamental les frontières sont
importantes les frontières entre les
hommes et les femmes les frontières
entre les pays et c'est ce qui ne veut
pas dire qu'une fois qu'on a une
frontière on peut pas l'ouvrir ce qu'il
va dire qu'une fois qu'on a une limite
on peut pas jouer avec cette limite
mais c'est très important et par
ailleurs dans la république française il
ya à la fois cette idée du contrat qui
est fondamental on est quand même une
société de citoyens avec une volonté qui
peut s'exprimer à travers le contrat et
c'est majeur mais on a aussi la loi
quand même et la loi elle peut disposer
et elle peut protéger parce que sinon on
se retrouve quand même il faut le dire
aussi dans la liberté du renard et du
poulailler quoi et cela dit qu à moi je
connais pas très bien le dossier en
question et je parle de vent
la compétence l'autorisent pas lire
l'autorité mais là il semble qu'il ya
une rupture unilatérale du contrat de
travail tout simplement quand on connaît
pas les faits l'expérience montre que
l'on connaît pas les faits les faits
c'est à dire les papiers les accords
mais voilà donc sous cette réserve mais
car sinon ça soit on l'a vu à ça car
nous n'avons que le que le point de vue
de la salariée plus pour l'instant
cora a refusé de se prononcer